super mario 64 sunshine and galaxy are
finally on nintendo switch in glorious
hd
but you might be wondering how some of
these games will control on the switch
how will flood work in sunshine without
the gamecube's analog triggers and how
will you play galaxy without motion
controls
well in this video we'll be breaking
down each game and talking about how
they've been adapted to play on nintendo
switch
and let me tell you the developers did a
fantastic job transitioning the controls
let's start with mario 64. this is
probably the least different of the
bunch but there are still some changes
worth mentioning first
you can use the right stick to move the
camera but it still clicks to fix
positions like you're hitting one of the
c buttons on the n64 controller
so you can't freely move it around in
full 360 degrees
this isn't exactly new as the virtual
console versions of mario 64 also did
this
but it's something to note if you
haven't played the game since the n64
or are playing it for the first time the
l r buttons still let you change the
camera mode from closer to farther away
the zl and zr buttons both act as the z
button from the n64 which allows you to
duck
crouch and perform other moves like the
long jump and ground pound
this is also true for jumping punching
kicking and swimming
now you can use a or b to jump and swim
on n64 those are both assigned to the a
button
you can now also use x or y to punch and
kick whereas these were done with the b
button on the n64
otherwise the controls are all the same
moving on to mario sunshine the most
notable change is how flood operates
the gamecube had what were called analog
triggers which essentially meant you
could push them lightly or down fully
for a different effect
in super mario sunshine you hit the r
button lightly to shoot water while
running and you press it all the way
down to stand still so you can aim and
spray
what nintendo did for the switch version
was take advantage of the r and zr
buttons
as you can see on the control screen
pressing z r gives you a running squirt
and pressing r allows you to stop and
squirt
if you do decide to stop and squirt
you'll need to press the right stick in
to get into mario cam which was y on the
gamecube controller
the guidebook was moved from the z
button on the gamecube controller to the
l button on the switch controller and zl
has become
center camera which was l on the
gamecube controller x is still used to
switch nozzles
and the gamecube style x button is still
shown on screen which is nice for fans
and keeping authenticity but
could be confusing for new players
speaking of changing button icons the b
button on the gamecube controller used
to be how you'd interact with npcs
but now you can use a or b and while the
game retains the red circle above
character's head since the
b button was a red circle on the
gamecube controller the letter inside
has
changed from b to a either will do the
trick despite it just saying a
actions that used to be assigned to b
like picking up items throwing items and
body slamming have been moved to the y
button
on the switch a and b are now just for
jumping swimming and talking
one final thing to note is that while
the gamecube controller could be plugged
into the switch through the adapter
release for super smash bros
sunshine will not take advantage of the
gamecube controller's functionality and
will instead act like a default usb
controller so what happens is the z
button on the gamecube controller
becomes what was zr
on the switch controller and the r
button on gamecube stays r
on the switch so you can stop and squirt
and do a running squirt but the l button
just opens the guidebook so you can't
center the camera which isn't a huge
deal
so it's definitely possible to play
sunshine on twitch with a gamecube
controller but all the buttons are
reassigned to mimic the switch
controller so it's not one-to-one with
the original
last but not least is super mario galaxy
which arguably has the most changes
since it was originally a wii game that
relied on motion controls
are you forced to use the joy-con
separated from mario galaxy and if so
how does it work on the switch light
well fear not because the button
controls are real
and they're spectacular so first let's
talk about how it works if you're
playing with a pro controller or
joy-cons on a grip
the gyro on both the pro controller and
joy cons work as the pointer
you still use that to select stuff on
the menu and collect star bits like with
the wii remote but
no sensor bar required this time if you
ever want to recenter the gyro all you
need to do is hit the r button
the biggest change in my opinion is that
you no longer need to shake the
controller to spin
which is a core mechanic to the game you
can now just press y or x
you can still shake the right joy con or
pro controller if you want but you don't
have to
jumping and swimming are now on both a
and b and while shooting star bits used
to be the b button on the wii remote now
it's on zr
on the switch zl now allows you to
crouch which was z
in the wii version and l resets the
camera which was c on the wii nunchuck
lastly before you can move the camera
with the d-pad on the wiimote but now
you can use the right stick
since it was originally on the d-pad it
isn't clicks just like mario 64 was and
despite having the right stick now it's
no different here
the co-star mode for mario galaxy also
makes a return where the game becomes
multiplayer and the second player is
only able to shoot star bits and stop
enemies it can be played with two
horizontal joy-cons two pro controllers
or any combination really it's not
limited to just two horizontal joy-cons
so now let's move on to handheld mode
which is also how the switch light will
operate
it's pretty much all the same except no
gyro functionality
instead you have to touch the screen to
select things and collect star bits
it's not bad but you have to move your
hand off the right joy con to do it
so you can't be jumping and collecting
star bits at the same time which you
can do with the joy cons of the pro
controller definitely play with the
controller if you can but handheld isn't
bad just less ideal
lastly and this applies to all three
games the select button is used to
suspend the game
check controls and actions and return to
the title selection if you want to
choose a different game
and that's it nintendo did a fantastic
job adapting each of these games to work
with switch controls and it's certainly
nice to have all these games in hd 2.
this gets me excited for the possibility
of how other wii games could come to
switch
skyward sword anyone if you have any
further questions about how the controls
work do not hesitate to comment down
below and i'll answer them as best as i
can
for more coverage on super mario 3d
all-stars including our review stay
tuned to gamespot
[Music]
you